[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le jeudi 6 juillet voici le programme de
ce soir une centaine d'élèves des deux
écoles incendiées à La Verrière durant
les émeutes ont été reçus au château et
au campus de Versailles aujourd'hui au
programme une visite des ateliers et des
jeux pour leur changer les idées avant
la fin de leur année scolaire qui a été
mouvementée on en parle avec la rectrice
de l'académie de Versailles pour les
juilletistes la première grande vague de
départ en vacances aura lieu ce week-end
l'occasion de refaire un point sur
l'état général de son véhicule avant de
prendre la route pneu frein lave-glace
nous serons également au péage de
Saint-Arnoult-en-Yvelines à la veille
des premiers départs qui s'a faut savoir
passer de nombreux automobilistes demain
et puis comme d'habitude le jeudi à
l'approche du week-end nous vous
donnerons nos idées de sortie dans les
Yvelines au programme un concert à La
Bergerie Nationale de Rambouillet du
Tromboline du trampoline en pleine forêt
mais aussi les animations pour cet été
dans les villes de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et ce sera
avec vous Gabriel Gontier bonsoir
bonsoir Mathilde avec nous également sur
ce plateau Charline Avenel bonsoir
bonsoir alors je le rappelle vous êtes
la rectrice de l'académie de Versailles
je le disais à l'instant une centaine
d'élèves des deux écoles incendiées à La
Verrière ont été reçus au château de
Versailles alors suite aux émeutes
urbaines dans les Yvelines ou plusieurs
établissements ont été touchés avec les
résultats du brevet et du bac je suppose
que cette semaine a été mouvementée pour
l'académie de Versailles une semaine
mouvementée cette semaine un peu moins
fort heureusement que la semaine
dernière qui était une semaine
évidemment compliquée pour l'ensemble
des des français des Yvelines
singulièrement mais voilà une semaine en
tout cas celle-ci qui se termine avec un
peu de joie et la venue en effet de ses
enfants de la rivière au campus de
Versailles et au château de Versailles
et donc on en parlera plus en détail
dans quelques instants dans cette
émission avec nous également sur ce
plateau une journaliste de la rédaction
de TV 78 régénérer bonsoir bonsoir
Mathilde vous allez nous présenter les
informations à retenir aujourd'hui dans
les Yvelines ce sera juste après les
prévisions météo de demain
[Musique]
matin nous devrions toujours avoir un
grand soleil dans les Yvelines au niveau
des températures comptées 18 degrés à
Rambouillet 19 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie
et 20 degrés à Houdan et Versailles dans
l'après-midi même tendance le soleil
sera au rendez-vous côté température le
thermomètre grimpe il fera 30 à 31
degrés en moyenne sur le département
et demain nous fêterons la saint Raoul
le pont maintenant sur les informations
du jour à retenir dans les Yvelines
[Musique]
et on commence avec cette information
Régine aujourd'hui la cour d'appel de
Versailles à statué sur la remise en
liberté du policier qui a tué Anaël le
mardi 27 juin et la Cour a décidé du
maintien en détention provisoire du
policier suspecté d'avoir tué Naël lors
d'un contrôle routier à Nanterre le 27
juin dernier ce moteur de la police a
été mis en examen pour homicide
volontaire son avocat déplore cette
décision c'est la rue qui tient la
justice a-t-il déclaré au micro de nos
confrères de BFM TV la remise des prix
du challenge vélo inter-entreprise a eu
lieu hier et c'était la fin de ce
challenge qui avait débuté le 30 mai
dernier pour cette troisième édition 21
entreprises et collectivités de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ont participé
au Challenge deux épreuves individuelles
et une épreuve collective était proposée
le but réaliser des trajets domicile
entreprise je vous propose tout de suite
d'écouter Jean-Baptiste à Monique
vice-président délégué au transport et à
la mobilité durable faut qu'on accélère
qu'on mette un coup d'accélérateur
justement sur la pour faire du
vélo une mobilité à part entière du
quotidien et donc c'est ce que nous
avons fait avec notre schéma directeur
cyclable je rappelle c'est 38 millions
d'euros d'investissement et c'est aussi
ce que nous faisons en faisant la
promotion avec nos entreprises et bien
de du vélo au quotidien et notamment des
déplacements domicile travail qui ont
été effectués par un peu plus de 200
participants sur un mois
et on va maintenant parler de médecine
et plus précisément de chirurgie
orthopédique hier avait lieu à la Ferme
du Manet de Montigny-le-Bretonneux une
grande rencontre entre professionnels de
santé oui et cette grande rencontre
annuelle était organisée par des
chirurgiens orthopédiques de l'Hôpital
Privé de l'Ouest parisien à Trappes
médecin du sport rhumatologue ou encore
kinésie thérapeute ils étaient
280 professionnels avoir répondu présent
l'objectif de la soirée c'était de faire
le point sur les techniques
chirurgicales et de présenter les
dernières avancées on écoute tout de
suite les réactions au micro de Julien
Leroy une des plus grandes difficultés
des médecins aujourd'hui c'est de
réussir à rester informés c'est-à-dire
qu'on a beaucoup de notre temps qui est
utilisé à soigner et on doit continuer à
se former c'est grâce à ces réunions qui
ont réussi à échanger et d'évolutions
technologiques en chirurgie ont pour but
de réduire les durées d'hospitalisation
rendre la chirurgie moins invasive avec
des cicatrices moins importantes et des
durées de récupération vont être
beaucoup plus courtes avant de la
chirurgie ouverte et là maintenant la
chirurgie mini invasive et donc
arthroscopique permettent de faire des
micro-incisions pour réparer tous les
tous les ligaments qui sont rompus
qui n'existants quand ça fait longtemps
qu'ils sont qui ne sont plus là on va
rentrer du coup dans dans les
articulations donc du poignet pour aller
voir et réparer les ligaments et
les tissus qui sont réparables sur
l'arroscopie un mot de sport à présent
et plus particulièrement de tennis c'est
déjà terminé pour Arthur Rinder knees et
le tennisman originaire de Saint-Germain
en laisse c'est incliné dès le premier
tour du tournoi Wimbledon à Londres
c'est le français Alexandre Muller qui a
remporté le match de plus de deux heures
avec un score de 7 6 1 6 6 3 et 6 4 et
comme chaque année à l'occasion de la
Saint-Fiacre la traditionnelle reine de
la Fête des Loges a été élu oui et
l'heureuse élue s'appelle Léna lisions
elle s'est vu remettre son titre par le
maire de Saint-Germain-en-Laye Arnaud à
Péricard toute l'année elle l'assurera
sa mission en allant à la rencontre des
enfants hospitalisés et les personnes
âgées dans les maisons de retraite à
noter également que la Fête des Loges se
tiendra jusqu'au 20 août 2023 et demain
ce sera le début des grandes vacances
d'été scolaires quels sont les
prévisions sur les routes régimes alors
pour ce dernier pour ce premier weekend
le trafic routier se densifie dans le
sens des départs notamment en
Île-de-France vendredi Bison Futé voie
rouge il est conseillé de quitter ou de
traverser la région avant 5h du matin
samedi la région sera classée en orange
la circulation sera difficile et le car
nord-ouest de la France sera quant à lui
classé rouge Bison Futé conseil cette
fois-ci de quitter l'île de France avant
midi et enfin dimanche les cartes se
remettent au vert la circulation sera
fluide dans toute la France pas de
difficultés particulières au niveau du
trafic et bien merci beaucoup Régine
ralege pour toutes ces informations et
comme d'habitude si vous aussi vous
voyez une image ou une information qui
vous a marqué près de chez vous
n'hésitez pas à nous la partager sur les
réseaux sociaux en utilisant le hashtag
78 news
vous l'entendiez à l'instant ça
s'annonce compliqué ce week-end sur les
routes avec les premiers départs pour
les vacances d'été direction tout de
suite la barrière de péage de
Saint-Arnoult-en-Yvelines pour retrouver
Grégory canalet sur place bonsoir
Grégory
bonsoir Mathilde alors on imagine que ce
sera l'effervescence demain là où vous
trouvez
effectivement ici sur cette barrière de
péage de Saint-Arnoult-en-Yvelines sur
l'autoroute A10 il devrait y avoir
beaucoup de passage demain un vendredi à
l'occasion de ce premier grand week-end
de départ en vacances ici à
saint-amand-en-yvelines on est sur la
plus grande barrière de péage en Europe
un 39 voix pour ce péage ici circule en
moyenne 80000 véhicules par jour ça peut
même monter à 170000 l'été et c'est le
point de passage quasi obligé on peut
dire si vous voulez vous rendre à Rennes
Nantes Bordeaux même plus au sud si vous
allez vers l'Espagne ou le Portugal
alors je suis avec Jean-Baptiste
jouannig bonsoir bonsoir le chef de
district Île-de-France pour VINCI
Autoroutes comment se mobilise vos
équipes à la veille de ce premier grand
week-end de départ en vacances alors oui
effectivement c'est parti les équipes de
Vinci Autoroutes sont pleinement
mobilisées pour assurer la sécurité sur
l'autoroute qui va de paire à la
fluidité nous avons doublé les effectifs
et tout est prêt pour que les vacances
commencent dès qu'on arrive sur
l'autoroute alors on a pu visiter votre
centre d'information trafic de
saint-arné-en-yvelines on va peut-être
savoir quelques images s'afficher dans
un instant Bison Futé voit un trafic
quand même compliqué on peut le
comprendre en ce premier grand week-end
de départ en vacances à quoi vous
attendez-vous sur le réseau VINCI
Autoroutes est-ce que peut-être vous
avez des conseils donner aux
automobilistes sur leur pour prendre la
route leur idéal alors oui le trafic va
être un peu compliqué ce weekend on
attend si vous voulez retenir un chiffre
4 millions d'automobilistes sur la zone
autoroute ce qui est ce qui est assez
grand ce qu'on peut conseiller aux
automobilistes c'est de décaler un tout
petit peu leur départ soit en amont en
partant très tôt le matin après une
bonne nuit il faut d'abord bien se
reposer avant de partir soit un peu plus
tard le soir avec les mêmes
préconisations et pour pour le repos et
puis pendant le trajet il faut que ça
soit déjà les vacances il faut prendre
son temps il faut se reposer faire une
pause toutes les deux heures pour être
bien apte à conduire on a parlé de la
mobilisation alors en première ligne il
y a notamment les patrouilleurs leur
rôle on le sait est primordial mais ils
peuvent parfois être en insécurité à
cause du manque de vigilance des
automobilistes on a recensé 27 heures
sur le réseau Vinci aut depuis le début
de l'année quel conseil pourriez-vous
donner aux automobilistes pour un
maximum de sécurité sur vos autoroutes
alors oui j'insiste un peu sur ce
message un peu fort 27 heures c'est
beaucoup trop et donc c'est pas
trouilleur qui sont là c'est un peu les
anges gardiens de l'autoroute ils vont
intervenir tout de suite pour protéger
tous ceux qui sont dans des situations
de détresse il faut également faire
attention à eux et on appelle si on a ce
qu'on appelle le corridor de sécurité
qui consiste à se décaler d'une voie dès
qu'on voit un fourgon en intervention
sur le bord du tracé c'est très
important il en va de la sécurité 2 mais
de tout le monde également et pour
terminer un ou deux conseils donner aux
automobilistes pour aussi prendre la
route en toute sécurité on a envie de
dire faire des pauses c'est déjà quelque
chose de primordial quand on fait la
route alors oui tout à fait il faut
faire des pauses toutes les conseils
toutes les deux heures sur nos aires qui
sont bien aménagés sur lequel on a des
étapes qui sont particulièrement là pour
accueillir nos usagers dans de bonnes
conditions il faut prendre le temps il
faut rester calme et tout va bien se
passer merci Jean-Baptiste Joigny pour
ces précisions alors pour rester informé
deux moyens à vos communiquer bien sûr
le 107.7 FM sur la radio pour avoir des
flashs infos trafic ou rendez-vous
directement sur les comptes Twitter des
autoroutes pour avoir toutes les
informations trafic et on le rappellera
jamais assez bien sûr rester prudent
et bien merci beaucoup Grégory canalet
pour toutes ces précisions et merci
également à Julien Leroy qui est au
moyen technique et pour tous ceux qui
ont prévu de partir en vacances avec
leur voiture cet été il est important de
vérifier si celle-ci est en bon état
gonflage des pneus vérification des
freins lave-glace le gérant du garage de
l'autoroute à Bois-d'Arcy nous donne ses
conseils pour une conduite en toute
sérénité c'est le reportage de Julien
Leroy
bonjour moi c'est José garage Citroën de
Bois-d'Arcy garage de l'autoroute nous
allons regarder aujourd'hui les
contrôles à faire éventuels avant chaque
départ de de pour les vacances
donc je vais vous montrer les deux trois
petits contrôles à effectuer avant avant
les départs c'est toujours mieux donc on
va contrôler un petit niveau d'huile le
mieux c'est d'attendre moteur froid ou
quand le moteur est chaud à de patienter
5 10 minutes pour que l'huile de
redescende dans la cuve donc on peut un
petit aller-retour surtout ne pas
dépasser le max qu'on soit entre les
deux c'est parfait ni en dessous du mini
ni au-dessus du Maxi voilà pour le
niveau d'huile
après nous avons le liquide de
refroidissement qui a le bocal à éviter
d'ouvrir un moteur chaud risque c'est
sous pression pareil nous avons la même
chose que le niveau de le niveau d'huile
nous avons un traçage minimum un traçage
maximum là on voit que le niveau de
liquide de refroidissement est
impeccable
ensuite nous avons le liquide de
lave-glace on le voit avec le petit
cycle de pare-brise là ça vous pouvez le
remplir au maximum aucun risque il n'y a
pas de problème donc on va contrôler que
le gicleur de lave-glace et les
essuie-glaces fonctionnent correctement
quand c'est possible on peut jeter un
œil sur le niveau de liquide de frein
donc c'est un peu plus difficile souvent
mais nous avons la même chose nous avons
un niveau minimum un niveau maximum si
vous voyez qu'il y a pas de liquide de
frein le mieux serait de se rapprocher
vers votre garagiste qui dit niveau trop
faible dit souvent plaquettes de frein
usées
nous avons vérifié l'éclairage donc on
va faire le tour du véhicule là j'ai mis
les feux de position on voit que c'est
allumé partout devant et derrière
et bon on va finir le contrôle par la
pression des pneumatiques la plaque
constructeur va nous donner la pression
pneumatique pour une utilisation dite
normale et la pression pneumatique une
utilisation chargée notamment pour les
départs en vacances
et donc pour l'usure du pneumatique nous
avons la bande de roulement et dans
chaque rainure nous avons un petit une
petite boursouflure qui va nous nous
montrer l'état d'usure du pneumatique
donc dès que la bande de roulement
arrive au même niveau que les
boursouflures ça veut dire que le pneu
est à remplacer
l'utilité de faire ces petits contrôles
avant de prendre la route c'est déjà
d'être un peu plus serein sur sur votre
trajet afin de débuter le tourisme de de
légères pannes éventuelle
parler à un début d'émission l'académie
de Versailles
illes par les émeutes urbaines la
semaine dernière pour en parler avec
nous la rectrice Charlène Charline
Avenel alors dans la ville de La
Verrière deux écoles ont été incendiées
aujourd'hui les élèves de et les
enseignants de ces deux écoles étaient
au château et au campus de Versailles
c'est une initiative de l'académie de
Versailles pourquoi avoir organisé cette
journée pour les enfants
dans l'académie de Versailles la semaine
dernière il y a eu une trentaine
d'écoles et d'établissements qui ont été
touchés dégradés
dans les émeutes urbaines que nous avons
connues il y a trois écoles qui ont été
plus sévèrement touchés dont deux écoles
à la verrière qui ont purement et
simplement
disparus en fumée après un incendie
criminel et volontaire qui a touché ces
deux écoles alors je me suis rendue
jeudi dernier
juste après le cet incendie qui avait
lieu la nuit c'était une image de
désolation que celle de ces deux écoles
entièrement brûlées détruites dans un
quartier dans lequel l'école est tout à
la fois pour ses habitants pour ses
élèves et aussi pour ceux qui y
travaillent
donc on était en pleine sidération les
enseignants ne comprenant pas pourquoi
l'école avait été prise à partie de
cette manière pourquoi elle n'était plus
là ils étaient assez désespérés nous
sommes allés à leur rencontre avec le
maire le préfet et puis hier et
aujourd'hui il y a encore eu des visites
importantes notamment la présidente de
région qui s'est rendue sur place et je
veux dire que voilà on a été à l'écoute
d'abord de ce choc très fort pour chacun
à l'écoute pour donner de
l'accompagnement psychologique et puis
pour commencer entrevoir l'avenir alors
l'avenir la semaine dernière c'était
demain c'était savoir comment allait se
passer l'école vendredi donc on a trouvé
des solutions et puis on a commencé à
imaginer comment se passerait la semaine
qui suivrait et puis maintenant on est
en train d'imaginer comment va se passer
la rentrée donc tout est réglé
les enfants vont pouvoir aller à l'ERPD
la verrière qui appartient à la région
c'est une école de premier degré
régional tout à fait assez rare assez
atypique mais ça appartient en effet à
la région qui est d'accord et Valérie
Pécresse a donné son accord pour que
nous puissions à la rentrée scolarisée
les enfants et donc ces mises en place
une très jolie solidarité autour des
enseignants des élèves de tous ceux qui
travaillent solidarité qui a permis de
trouver des fournitures des fournitures
pour la rentrée on en manque encore un
petit peu de trouver ce lieu à l'ERPD la
verrière et donc voilà on est à l'oeuvre
pour préparer cette rentrée et pourquoi
le RPD c'était la solution la plus
facile à mettre en place c'est à
proximité donc c'était vraiment
assez à ses idéal je dois dire et une
configuration tout à fait agréable dans
lesquelles dans lesquelles les enfants
vont pouvoir s'épanouir c'était
disponible en tout cas très peu rempli
et donc voilà c'est vraiment la bonne
solution mais il faut beaucoup de bonnes
volonté et beaucoup d'actions pour faire
les quelques mètres qui maintenant vont
nous séparer de la rentrée mais voilà je
crois que les enseignants sont très
soulagés de cette solution de la
solidarité qui s'est exprimée et de
pouvoir réaborder la rentrée sereinement
alors entre temps et bien je dis donc
lorsque nous y étions je l'ai dit
c'était vraiment la sidération le choc
et j'ai eu cette idée dans quel état
sont les élèves les parents et puis même
les enseignants le personnel de l'école
alors les enseignants étaient vraiment
très en questionnements y compris sur
sur leur rôle le rôle de l'école dans la
sidération de penser que des jeunes qui
peut-être ont été les grands frères ou
sont eux-mêmes passés par cette école
ont pu porter atteinte
à ce bien commun que l'école donc je
dois dire que jeudi lorsque je suis allé
les voir ils étaient évidemment
naturellement sidérés ils avaient les
traits tirés ils étaient éprouvés et
puis j'étais aussi très touchée par les
Atsems vous savez les assistantes
maternelle qui souvent travaillent et
habitent dans la ville et donc ces
personnes étaient choquées parce
qu'elles ont vécu des violences dans les
immeubles et donc voilà c'était le choc
et la sidération jeudi dernier
l'incompréhension également mais à cela
j'ai pu leur dire les parents les
enfants rentraient très choqué aussi ils
le sont encore et donc on les accompagne
sur le plan psychologique il y a eu des
cellules d'écoute et puis un dispositif
qui continuera à être ouvert pendant
l'été
personne ne comprend tout le monde est
choqué et évidemment il faut prendre
soin d'eux et ce que je leur ai dit
au-delà de l'écoute nécessaire au-delà
de leur dire que nous allions être à
leur côté et bien c'était que plus que
jamais l'école l'éducation était
nécessaire et qu'il fallait pas se
résigner bien au contraire que on avait
besoin de donc j'espère leur avoir donné
un peu de souffle
ce sont des écoles qui ont été visées
par les émeutiers c'est un symbole de la
République
honnêtement je n'ai pas d'explication
je n'ai pas d'explication à ce qui
suscite une incompréhension totale c'est
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'on nous
sommes sidérés et cette école c'est une
école qui qui fonctionne très bien il y
a très beau projet pédagogiques les
jeunes de la ville sont passés par cette
école donc c'est incompréhensible
et il fallait pouvoir leur donner
de l'assurance sur ce qui allait se
passer nous l'avons fait collectivement
et puis nous avons souhaité leur donner
aussi un petit peu de joie pour finir
quel était l'objectif finir sur une une
touche positive en fait l'idée m'est
venue lorsque nous déambulions avec la
directrice d'école qui était très
marquée sur les cendres de l'école et
j'ai eu cette idée en lui disant mais on
a tous besoin de beau on a besoin de
respirer que diriez-vous devenir la
semaine prochaine à Versailles et j'ai
vu son visage éclairer alors que c'était
dans un moment assez assez difficile
pour tout le monde elle portait sur ses
épaules beaucoup de choses et puis le
soutien de cette équipe et donc quand
j'ai vu son sourire et et voilà la joie
et l'espoir que ça suscitait et bien
nous nous sommes mis en situation
d'organiser cette belle journée donc à
la fois au château dans le campus de
Versailles avec des ateliers gastronomie
goût des ateliers aussi d'origami j'y
suis passée tout à l'heure et je ne sais
pas si les enfants ont eu le temps
d'aller visiter la galerie des carrosses
qui avait ouverte le château de
Versailles je l'espère mais en tout cas
voilà j'ai vu d'abord les traits des
enseignants beaucoup plus reposés que la
semaine dernière évidemment et puis j'ai
vu des enfants enjoués et qui je
l'espère vont emporter avec pour ses
vacances cette dernière image de leur
année scolaire qui sera je crois une
jolie image
justement vous avez pu échanger un petit
peu avec les enfants qu'est-ce qu'ils
sont pensés de ces journées à ce que ça
le les a libérés un petit peu des images
qu'ils ont dû voir aussi à la télé comme
n'importe qui alors j'ai pas parlé je
n'ai pas parlé avec les enfants de ce
qui s'était passé la semaine dernière
parce qu'ils avaient déjà eu pas mal de
d'assistante et notamment psychologique
dans là aujourd'hui on était dans la
joie dans la contemplation je les ai vus
notamment vous savez à la Grande Écurie
là où est le campus il y a il y a le
l'écurie de Bartabas donc il y avait des
chevaux pour certains c'était la
première fois qu'il voyait des chevaux
donc ils étaient ébahis contents et
trouvant assez beau ce qu'ils avaient
sous les yeux il ne semblait pas marquer
parce qu'il s'est passé non je crois
qu'ils étaient heureux d'être ensemble
comme tous les enfants et de faire une
journée de fin d'année scolaire
dans la joie alors au tout début vous
nous expliquez qu'il y avait trois qu'il
y a trois écoles qui ont été sévèrement
touchés dans l'académie de Versailles
par les émeutes urbaines il y a l'école
du bois de l'étang à La Verrière l'école
maternelle des Noé également à la
verrière quelle est la troisième école
c'est une école dans le Val-d'Oise à
Bezons où s'est rendu la première
ministre et le ministre de l'éducation
nationale ainsi que le ministre Klein la
semaine dernière les dégâts sont moins
importants mais mes enfants
en tout cas la semaine dernière il nous
a paru vraiment important d'aller à la
rencontre des des enseignants et puis là
aussi de trouver des solutions et
d'accompagner les uns et les autres
alors dans l'actualité également
Charline Avenel les résultats du bac et
du brevet qui sont tombés ces derniers
jours cette semaine quels sont les taux
de réussite du bac dans l'académie de
Versailles alors sur le bac général on
est à 89 5 façon de réussite au niveau
académique
92,8% pour les Yvelines pour le bac
technologique 73,2 % de réussite au
niveau académique et 80,2 dans les
Yvelines et puis pour le bac
professionnel 72,7 au niveau académique
et 75,7 dans les Yvelines donc vous
voyez les Yvelines se caractérisent par
un petit bonus moi je voudrais féliciter
tous les candidats qui sont maintenant
des bacheliers et qui vont pouvoir
rentrer dans l'enseignement supérieur et
pour le brevet est-ce que vous avez les
chiffres également alors le brevet c'est
le scoop puisque les les données les
résultats sont sortis cet après-midi
donc on avait cette année beaucoup de
candidats en plus ils étaient 900 en
plus et puis les résultats nous donnent
90,35% pour la voie générale du brevet
pour les Yvelines là aussi un petit
bonus de
90,95% donc là aussi je félicite les les
jeunes gens qui ont passé avec succès ce
brevet c'est sérieux de passer des
examens et voilà ça suppose et ça
suscite la fierté en tout cas voilà les
jeunes peuvent être fiers de leurs
efforts et heureux d'avoir fait tout ce
parcours et alors l'année dernière il y
avait des collégiens qui étaient sans
affectation au lycée en raison d'un
nombre insuffisant de place est-ce que
cette année on va rencontrer le même
problème
à la rentrée on sera là aussi sûrement
un petit peu en tension sur les
affectations en seconde pour la voix
professionnelle
voilà ça s'explique à la fois par la
démographie qui est très dynamique dans
notre académie singulièrement dans
l'Essonne et dans le Val-d'Oise moins
dans les Yvelines et moins dans les
Hauts-de-Seine ça s'explique aussi par
le temps que prend la transformation de
l'offre de formation pour être
complètement compatible avec les à la
fois les souhaits des jeunes et puis les
besoins d'emploi et puis enfin et bien
tout cela traduit aussi les efforts que
nous avons encore à faire en matière
d'orientation pour trouver à chacun le
bon parcours bref une rentrée qui sera à
surveiller du point de vue
désaffectations nous sommes au travail
avec mes équipes les équipes de chaque
département pour et bien travailler au
mieux pour que la rentrée se fasse dans
les meilleures conditions et que les
élèves puissent
bien aller dans une voie qui leur
convienne et bien merci beaucoup
Charline avenelle d'avoir accepté notre
invitation en plateau je le rappelle
vous êtes la rectrice de l'académie de
Versailles avec ces 231 m d'altitude la
colline artificielle dès l'encours et le
point culminant de la région parisienne
un dénivelé qui lui a permis d'être
sélectionné pour les épreuves de VTT
lors des Jeux olympiques de Paris 2024
pour se faire la société solideo société
de livraison des ouvrages olympiques
s'est occupé des aménagements après
plusieurs mois de travaux elle devrait
bientôt remettre les clés de la piste
olympique c'est le reportage de Céline
Charles et de William Morel virage
relevé la sépaus ou encore chemin
rocheux pas de doute la colline
d'Élancourt est presque prête pour la
compétition depuis plusieurs mois elle
est en cours d'aménagement par la
société de livraison des ouvrages
olympiques zone spectateur espace
logistique mais surtout piste de plus de
4 km
de la Solidaire délivrera à la fin du
mois de juillet un aménagement clé en
main et soucieux de l'écosystème
environnant la piste est quasiment
terminée il nous reste à peu près un
mois pour finaliser certains ouvrages on
a certains tremplins en bois par exemple
ici qui vont être réalisés dans les
quatre semaines à venir on a pris un
certain nombre de dispositions aussi
pour réduire le plus possible les
impacts du chantier de l'événement par
exemple il y a aucun éclairage qui a mis
en place qui perturbe pas donc la faune
la nuit par exemple il y a les clôtures
de sécurité du chantier qui ont été
surélevés pour permettre le passage de
la petite faune il y a des espaces qui
sont sanctuarisés la piste sera
expérimentée les 23 et 24 septembre
nombre prochain par les meilleurs
vététistes mondiaux lors d'un test event
une répétition grandeur nature de
l'épreuve de cross country olympique de
Paris 2024 l'objet pour Paris 2024 c'est
donc de tester de toutes les façons
possibles le site par exemple de voir si
les pompiers peuvent bien passer pour
intervenir si besoin par exemple de voir
si la piste est pas trop dangereuse pour
les athlètes par exemple de voir si
c'est facile du point de vue de la
retransmission de l'événement après les
Jeux place à l'héritage l'objectif est
de faire de la colline un parc sportif
et paysager pour les habitants du
territoire s'appuyer sur la piste
olympique de VTT en recréant de
nouvelles pistes avec des nouveaux
difficultés différents du mobilier
sportif des agrets ludiques pour les
enfants la conservation de la piste
naturellement la piste olympique ça va
servir de de
supports de compétition l'objectif c'est
de pouvoir réaccueillir une compétition
des entraînements à des niveaux très
importants dans le futur les épreuves de
VTT des jeux se dérouleront les 28 et 29
juillet 2024 aucun véhicule ne sera
autorisé sur place les 15000 spectateurs
attendus devront se rendre sur le site
en navette
allez c'est l'heure à présent de passer
à notre page loisirs
[Musique]
et on ouvre cette page loisirs avec de
la lecture cet été les médiathèques de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines participent à
l'action nationale partir en livre pour
en parler avec nous Marie-Pierre Caruel
bonsoir bonsoir alors vous êtes la
responsable politique d'action
culturelle pour le réseau des
médiathèques de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines première
question c'est quoi l'événement partir
en livre alors partir en livre comme
vous l'avez dit c'est un événement
national qui est organisé par le Centre
national du livre surtout le territoire
français et par le salon du livre
jeunesse de Montreuil donc les experts
de la littérature jeunesse et cette
année donc ils ont choisi comme
thématique la liberté nous avons pris
quelques libertés avec la liberté cet
investissement
et donc nous avons choisi de
proposer plutôt des activités autour de
l'arbre du vivant voilà et comme c'est
ce qui intéresse le plus les jeunes mais
en fait c'est un événement qui est
destiné à être proposé hors les murs des
médiathèques donc dans les parcs les
jardins sur les plages liées en général
aux activités des villes toutes les
quartiers d'été on organise ces journées
en lien avec les communes donc sur leurs
événements festifs de l'été et donc il y
a beaucoup de parcs enfin il y a
beaucoup de parcs beaucoup de jardins et
la thématique de l'arbre et de la nature
se prêtait bien au sujet et alors cette
année on a une héroïne super qui nous
accompagne pour partir en livre fichier
c'est l'affiche de du parti en livre
2023 donc c'est mortel Adèle donc une
héroïne que les enfants apprécient
beaucoup et des activités alors on a
prévu autour de mortelle Adèle déjà de
pouvoir lire les livres dans parce qu'on
propose sur chaque action un espace
lecture donc avec toute la collection de
mortels qui sera à disposition alors on
peut trouver des enfants peuvent trouver
aussi des cartes à colorier des cartes
postales que pour Android
à l'ancienne
ils peuvent aussi trouver sur le portail
des médias une page dédiée à partir en
livre à l'événement donc ou sur lequel
on peut trouver donc le programme
complet qui se déroule donc sur les 12
communes de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
sans exception
le programme une affiche à colorier des
sélections de lecture autour de la
liberté un par exemple une sélection de
musique aussi autour de puisqu'on a des
ressources en ligne sur le portail donc
autour
alors des lectures autour de la liberté
et puis on va vous y proposer des
lectures pour l'été enfin donc
différentes sélections proposées par les
bibliothèques donc ça c'est sur le site
et justement en termes de lecture c'est
assez varié il y a un thème en
particulier où il y en a vraiment pour
tous les goûts alors on a privilégié la
thématique de la liberté au moins pas
sur la proposition artistique
d'animation mais sur le sur les
sélections de livres
cette sélection justement vous pouvez
nous en donner peut-être que les
sélections moi-même je ne les ai pas
préparés donc je voudrais pas vous dire
des bêtises
à découvrir voilà j'invite tout le tout
public à se rendre sur le portail donc
i- médiathèque.fr le site pour en savoir
plus qui s'affiche à l'écran pourquoi
faire sortir les livres des médiathèques
c'est pour aller plus facilement vers
les jeunes alors l'idée c'est de
proposer effectivement des activités ou
les publics se trouvent pendant l'été et
les médiathèques m'ont sont grandes
ouvertes alors il y a des petits
réductions de d'ouverture donc pour info
pareil sur le site
on peut trouver les horaires d'ouverture
proposé en juillet août
pour la lecture vis-à-vis des jeunes ils
lisent encore
les jeunes lisent toujours mais les
effectivement la lecture c'est quand
même un sujet
passif évident alors tout est lecture
quand on est quand on utilise un
smartphone on lit aussi la lecture
change la lecture est plus de leur du
zapping peut-être qu'on lit moins de
roulement et encore il y a des il y a
beaucoup de jeunes qui s'y trouvent le
bon genre le bon style qui leur convient
peuvent dévorer des livres donc les
jeunes continuent à lire ils lisent
différemment je pense
que c'est plutôt ça la tendance actuelle
ils disent différemment et du coup vous
vous adaptez en sortant ce livre des
médiathèques vous pensez que ça va aussi
attirer des lecteurs qui ne se
connaissent pas encore alors
effectivement je pense que les
médiathèques sont quand même des lieux
dans lesquels il faut avoir la volonté
de se rendre et c'est pas c'est
quelquefois c'est aussi
peut-être trop souvent associé à l'école
bibliothèque école il y a un lien assez
familier en tout cas dans l'esprit des
familles des parents très scolaires
alors qu'on n'est pas du tout sur les
mêmes enjeux on est on est là pour
proposer toutes sortes de de lecture de
mais aussi de la musique du cinéma déjà
on a on a différents supports et puis on
est là pour la lecture plaisir et pas
pour apprendre à lire ou voilà il est
vraiment sur le versant loisir beaucoup
plus
les murs on espère et on souhaite très
vivement pouvoir trouver des publics qui
naturellement n'iraient pas en
médiathèque alors au cours de
l'événement les enfants seront aussi
conviés à participer à une œuvre
collective et il y aura une pinte un
compteur et un botaniste est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire plus voilà alors le
projet fil rouge de cet été de partir en
livre c'est la création d'une oeuvre
collective à partir d'ateliers qui vont
être réalisés sur les 12 communes
animé donc par une peintre illustratrice
et qui s'appelle Héloïse Robin qui fait
un travail magnifique je vous invite
vraiment à découvrir l'album qu'elle
allait illustré écrit par comment il
s'appelle Laurent azuelo donc qui est à
la fois botaniste et compteur c'est la
même personne donc il est botaniste au
Muséum d'histoire naturelle et il est
également compteur et donc il va animer
des ateliers autour des arbres de
l'arbre frères autour de la notion de de
du calendrier celtique c'est-à-dire que
dans le calendrier celtique en fonction
de sa date de naissance on a la
correspondance d'un arbre qui nous qui
correspond à notre personnalité à nos
valeurs et donc chaque participant aux
ateliers sera invité à trouver son arbre
frère déjà après à le concevoir au
niveau graphique à le découper et sur
chaque ville à partir de tous ces arbres
il y aura création d'une petite forêt
suspendue ce serait une espèce de mobile
suspendue et après à la suite de tous
ces ateliers rendez-vous le 30 septembre
à la galerie
la galerie d'exposition de la ville de
Guyancourt pour découvrir
tous ces toutes ces créations et cette
création collective donc là il y aura
vraiment un moment festif avec une
déambulation du compteur qui aura
réalisé pendant les ateliers alors soit
des haïku il y aura peut-être écrit des
haïku suivant son inspiration soit des
haïku soit des alors des high pousse
sont de cours poèmes
je me sens que c'est 4 verres il y a des
contraintes très très spéciales
d'origine c'est c'est sa partie à la
culture japonaise et c'est en général
pour traduire un sentiment l'impression
du moment voilà suivant une forme
stylistique assez
est déterminé bien rendez-vous le 30
septembre alors merci beaucoup
Marie-Pierre careuelle d'avoir accepté
notre invitation en plateau alors pour
rappel partir en livre c'est jusqu'au
1er septembre dans toute les
médiathèques de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines vous
retrouverez toutes les informations sur
le site Internet qui s'affiche sur votre
écran après la lecture de l'art à
présent dans votre sept huit et plus
particulièrement de l'art contemporain
pour sa 26e édition sculpture en île
associée l'art avec l'écologie et la
nature au total 11 œuvres sont à
découvrir jusqu'au 1er octobre de la
gare de Saint-Lazare à Paris jusqu'à
l'île Nancy à Andrésy nous nous sommes
rendus sur place avec Nicolas dandry
[Musique]
jusqu'au 1er octobre les visiteurs sont
amenés à découvrir la 26ème édition de
sculpture en ligne l'exposition d'art
contemporain de Paris à Andrésy
accueille 10 artistes et 11 œuvres
celles-ci sont installés dans le parc de
l'Hôtel de Ville mais surtout sur l'île
de Nancy un lieu préservé où nous nous
sommes rendus en bateau
le thème de cette année retour aux
sources les artistes ont alors imaginé
des œuvres avec des matériaux qu'ils ont
uniquement trouvé sur l'île Nancy comme
Sarah favrillo qui a fabriqué une
pirogue à partir des troncs d'arbres du
site où Jonas de lait qui a sculpté des
haut-parleurs en bois d'érable qui
miment le bruit de certains oiseaux le
message que souhaite faire passer
l'artiste crie d'alarme d'une
biodiversité en péril
et sur le parcours on croise également
la route d'une étrange cabane alors il y
a notamment l'oeuvre de Margo fontaine
dans laquelle nous sommes ici qui est un
château d'intention
donc cet artiste fait partie des de 200
travaux soit des lèvres soit des cols
soit deux d'andrésiens ou d'autres
personnes qui ont voulu bien participer
à son œuvre
collaborative et les parties de peinture
végétale et de surtout de soins des
habitants ou des personnes qui ont voulu
voilà faire mettre en exergue leurs vœux
à la manière d'un château tibétain ou
les vœux s'envolent donc voilà chacun a
fait sa petite amie sa petite graine les
enfants ont parfois mis des notamment
sur la nature finalement c'est assez
interactif parce qu'il y a beaucoup
d'oeuvres ou les personnes qui visitent
peuvent venir essayer il y a aussi
beaucoup de points de nature c'est
important aussi d'intégrer ce type
d'oeuvre dans sculpture en ligne c'est
aussi un virage qu'on a voulu cette
année par rapport un vrai moment
disruptif par rapport à aux autres
éditions d'avant là c'est vraiment
effectivement il y a beaucoup de
participatifs beaucoup de collaboratifs
il y a eu beaucoup de bénévoles qui ont
utilisé
leur temps enfin qu'on donnait leur
temps pour participer aux œuvres avec
les artistes et effectivement il y a de
la collaboration au niveau des œuvres
elles-mêmes vous êtes aussi maîtresse
dans une école élémentaire les marottes
à Andrésy et du coup l'école a participé
à deux œuvres avec les enfants est-ce
que vous pouvez nous en dire un mot on
s'est aperçu que les arbres risseaux
donc les arbres de quand on les achète
chez les pépinières et East ou des
choses comme ça été effectivement
emprisonnés pour qu'on les repère bien
pour éviter la tente etc et c'est vrai
qu'au bout de 15 20 ans c'est c'est
plastique était toujours en serré autour
de du tronc d'arbre donc les enfants ont
décidé d'enlever tous les plastiques on
les a on a utilisés pour les deux
productions de des maternelles pour le
radeau des marottes et aussi également
pour le filet de le pêcheur de filet
[Musique]
autre changement cette année sculpture
en ligne propose 11 points d'observation
sur la nature qui nous entoure poisson
cimes des arbres oiseaux insectes il
nous invite ainsi à prendre le temps de
vivre et à se ressourcer au contact de
la nature le thème de cette année est
respecté
[Musique]
allez on poursuit cette page loisirs par
vos idées de sortie Gabriel comme
d'habitude à l'approche du weekend vous
partagez vos bons plans et pour ce
premier weekend de vacances d'été vous
nous avez sélectionné cinq sorties
plutôt familiales oui et Bonne Nouvelle
vos communes organisent de nombreux
événements pour l'été des samedis les
inhymontins vont pouvoir profiter du
retour d'été en sable au programme des
animations tout public et familiales
plages de sable transat structure
gonflable de quoi commencer les vacances
dès ce week-end Mathilde victime de son
succès seuls les habitants de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux peuvent désormais
profiter du lieu pour cela vous devez
faire votre demande de carte passée 2023
sur le site Montigny 78.fr mais pas de
jaloux il y a d'autres communes aussi
qui vont se transformer en station
balnéaire cet été oui par exemple à
plaisir les jeunes retrouveront les
quartiers d'été dès le 11 juillet à mon
repas esti jeune débute le 10 juillet
c'est également le pour d’un été à
Coignières du 8 au 16 juillet la ville
se transforme et prend des airs de club
de vacances pendant toute cette période
des activités sont proposées en voici
quelques-unes escalade tournois de
en élu et à dos poney ou encore
grand barbecue de quoi bien profiter des
longues journées d'été alors profitez
des longues journées d'été mais aussi
des longues soirées d'été et justement
la Bergerie Nationale de Rambouillet
nous en propose une oui et vous les
receviez hier Mathilde pour clôturer le
festival de La Bergerie samedi soir
l'établissement vous propose une grande
soirée à partir de 15h vous pourrez
profiter des animations culturelles
musicales et de nombreux spectacles dès
18h animations concert vous attendent
dans la cour royale de la Bergerie
Nationale ou des groupes se succéderont
toute la soirée en revanche cette année
le feu d'artifice sera annulé en raison
de la sécheresse qui touche notre
département je vous propose de regarder
l'interview complète qui est disponible
sur Youtube conc dans l'événement et il
y aura également des soirées festives à
Guyancourt Gabriel oui vendredi et
samedi c'est la fête à l'Ermitage dans
la commune de Guyancourt animation
spectacle de danse cinéma en plein air
rythme rond le week-end des concerts
seront également proposés à l'affiche
Saint-Quentin gospel ou encore l'artiste
burkinabéenne Candy Guira samedi à 15h
c'est le carnaval d'été sur le thème des
mille et une couleur qui se lancera et
on termine en prenant un peu de hauteur
Gabriel à l'espace à l'Espace
Rambouillet oui un peu de hauteur car
cette sortie se passe dans les arbres
Mathilde dès le 9 juillet les visiteurs
du parc de l'Espace Rambouillet vont
pouvoir profiter de trampoline géants
suspendus au beau milieu de la forêt
inspiré des trampolines des catamarans
et c'est accessible dès 4 ans j'espère
qu'il y aura aussi des trampoline pour
les plus grands comme tout le monde moi
ça m'intéresse merci beaucoup Gabriel
Gontier pour toutes ces idées de sortie
c'est bientôt la fin de cette émission
mais juste avant de se quitter je vous
propose de jeter un dernier coup d'oeil
aux prévisions météo de demain
demain matin nous devrions toujours
avoir un grand soleil dans les Yvelines
au niveau des températures comptées 18
degrés à Rambouillet 19 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et 20 degrés à Houdan et
Versailles dans l'après-midi même
tendance le saurai le soleil sera
toujours au rendez-vous côté température
le thermomètre grimpe il fera 30 à 31
degrés en moyenne sur le département et
pour les prévisions météo de ce week-end
c'est désormais Thomas Fletcher à la
présentation c'est devenu un rendez-vous
pour ce nouveau numéro alors quoi de
beau il est allé vous demander votre
programme pour les vacances de cet été
et je crois qu'il y aura beaucoup de
repos et beaucoup de détente
alors quoi de beau salut à tous alors
quoi de beau ce week-end dans les
Yvelines ce week-end c'est les départs
en vacances j'espère qu'il fera plus
beau là où vous allez que là où on est
actuellement là parce qu'il fait pas
magnifiquement beau j'espère que pendant
vos vacances vous allez pouvoir vous
reposer et vous détendre c'est vraiment
important de se reposer de se détendre
mais surtout de se détendre mais aussi
se reposer parce que le repos c'est
important mais la détente aussi c'est
l'avant-dernière météo de la saison donc
profitez de chaque instant c'est
important ce week-end apparemment il y a
des orages ça va donner dans les
chaumières je sais pas si c'est une
expression qui se dit on la garde en
tout cas vraiment content de cet été il
part sur les chapeaux de roue avec tout
cet orage là on adore toute cette pluie
on adore et puis on va voir avec vous du
coup où est-ce que vous partez en
vacances et si je peux me joindre à vous
et s'il y a une piscine à vague je serai
de la partie
vous partez en vacances monsieur oui 15
jours
vous allez où en Bretagne à côté de
Fougères ok ça c'est une plante ça
me reposer pas mal on peut venir
on partait en vacances la prochainement
oui bientôt allez quand samedi trop bien
vous allez où vous êtes dans une maison
camping on peut on peut savoir un peu
plus village vacances pas mal piscine il
y a des vagues dans la piscine non je
pense pas je peux faire les vagues
on pose des questions en rapport avec
les vacances vous avez des vacances de
prévues là pour cet été dans un dans un
hôtel un petit camping
il va falloir que je cotise ou faut que
oui sur
plus d'argent on est tous pris à la
gorge moi ça m'arrange pas du coup
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a croisé une collègue qui cherche des
bouquins sur le repos et la détente
surtout sur le repos par contre
la détente mais quand même le repos
vraiment
on garde vous avez des vacances de prévu
monsieur oui allez vous avez une piscine
hors sol oui ok ça m'intéresse moins
pourquoi revenir
mais alors
on va interviewer monsieur
c'est une veste
petit comment comme ça
[Rires]
comment via mon être
un peu plus large pour faire chauffer
avec mes parents
[Applaudissements]
alors quoi de beau
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir été avec nous je vous souhaite
une belle soirée sur TV 78 un bon
weekend et de belles vacances si vous
avez l'occasion de partir ce weekend
prenez soin de vous
[Musique]